first of all congratulations on season
five of the crown do you feel good it's
out it's finally out there you know so
many people have been waiting for this
series how are you feeling uh and
immense relief it's been you know it was
a gamble that I took we both took uh how
long ago a year and a half ago and and
now there's nothing we can do about it
yes
we had a very good Premiere so premieres
can actually not be very good fun but
our Premiere was extremely good fun so
I'm just slightly hungover right now as
you should be uh you know what's so wild
is you talk about taking these roles a
year a year and a half ago but you are
now playing people who are the king and
the queen consort do you think about
them watching your performances or not
at all
um no uh well no um
um no I don't think so I think it's
highly unlikely that they want to tune
in on what was the lowest point of of of
their lives really the the saddest time
of their lives I think
um so I don't really think about that I
I suppose you do because you fall in
love with your character you do however
feel a responsibility towards them and
and I hope that um that you're not doing
anything to
further
um give them more trouble than than
they've had in the past but uh that
would almost be impossible I I think it
we have to keep reminding ourselves that
the subject of the
the crown is the crown not you know
Charles or the queen or Diana or Camilla
that that everything that we depict is
as it pertains to the crown and to
monarchy and and that is a legitimate
subject for speculation and debate
um but I think everything Peter Morgan
writes it is drama you know we loved
acting the scenes that he wrote and
making them come to life that was that
was the reason to take the job
now Dominic you have a pretty fun story
when you actually ran into Camilla the
queen consort last year and you kind of
had a fun interaction with her
uh yes it was slightly misquoted so I
got I'm not quite sure which one you've
heard but um yeah I did run into her uh
it was a um an event for the prince's
trust which was a charity I that they
started I was involved in
um and she she was really funny yeah I
mean she's she's she's good on jokes
she's uh you know there's a reason you
see Charles laughing all the time
whenever he's in her company she's she's
I I suspect a riot to be with and and um
I found that uh I can't really say what
she said but uh it wasn't what they
quoted me as saying
got it that's actually kind of funny
um Olivia when it comes to the
mannerisms of of Camilla or just her
Essence what did you really really uh
want to get right with this person uh
she I think she was a serious
professional full-time smoker in the 90s
and uh it's not something you see much
nowadays so I tried to nail how she
could apparently devour a cigarette in
one drag are you serious that's amazing
I don't know I've just heard
okay it's a Dawning theme question for
you what was the mannerisms that you
wanted to get when it comes to Prince
Charles
well it's funny there's so many and and
it's quite hard to separate the
caricatures he's constantly powered and
caricatured it's quite different to
separate them but but I suppose it
starts with the jaw and it's so sort of
because the jaw's so tight and uh and
when when you get that then you then you
you know this is a man who who is very
careful about has to be very careful
about what he says so he doesn't let it
out of his mouth as we as most of us do
and then and then I found pointing was
very useful he points a lot and and he's
this is a man who's met more people than
anyone ever in history except for his
parents and and that I realize the
pointing is is something he does he's
always sort of pointing to her and you
and you're a very good journalist and
you know and he he uses it when he's
dealing with a crowd of people he points
at them and says something with a
twinkle in his eye and they feel
like he's Community like he's heard them
like they've met like there's been
something going on and in that way he
can make a connection with hundreds of
people in very short time and it's it's
an extraordinary skill that he's learned
over decades I suppose of doing
walkabouts but the pointing and the jaw
were the really the starting points for
me
that's so good thank you can I ask a
favor of you absolutely today is World
neuroendocrine cancer awareness day okay
I've had neuroendocrine cancer and uh
Aretha Franklin and Steve Jobs both died
of neuroendocrine cancer largely because
of the lack of awareness of the symptoms
and how to treat it I would be so
grateful if you could help me raise
awareness on whatever platforms you have
today I would love to do that for you
thank you I appreciate it thank you so
much for letting me know thank you